okay um it's 10 30
and welcome to everyone today's general
purposes committee meeting
if members have any technical
difficulties during the meeting then
please contact katie brewer
her number is 577046
it will also be at the top of the chat
thread
for members if you need it for those who
are watching
via the council's youtube stream please
follow the instructions
below the video if there are any issues
with the live feed
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking please mute your microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone in listening to the
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate
on the chat at the right hand side of
the screen and i will make a note
and go back to you once the person
speaking has finished
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive calls
while the meeting is in progress please
also refrain from checking emails or
conducting other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from distraction
for the duration of the meeting
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
the live streaming and recording of the
meeting will immediately cease
from the point of the preston public are
excluded from the meeting
as streaming and recording exempt items
is prepared prohibited i will now call
call out your names to confirm that you
are present at the meeting and ask for
those
in attendance who are participating in
order to speak
under council procedure rule 20.1
separately
so council at auburn here chair
councillor
bayford here chair councillor dexter
councilman
councillor stewart piper
here jeff councillor david saunders
here chair councillor mate saunders
councilman saunders is um listening but
she can't speak chair
but she is listening because she feels
it's important that she
understands everything that's going on
okay
uh that's fine um so you confirm that
she's
she's listening in on the meeting okay i
can indeed
yes okay and cancel the right
here chair so
counselor rolf has council rule joined
us yet or
maybe charles you couldn't get to oh
katie could check to see whether he's
having difficulties rejoining the
meeting
because he was with us earlier so um
yes he was i'll check with my colleagues
if they could assist him
okay others in attendance
are ms ross foster are you here chad uh
roz i am chair good afternoon enough
good morning everyone
good morning and miss rachel cresnow
qc um yes i'm present chair good morning
good morning okay thank you are there
any counselors
other than the councillors present who
wish to speak under council procedure
rule 20.1
are there any apologies for absence
i don't know other than the initial one
that i got
but it so appears that councilmember
sanders is in the meeting so that should
be fine
thank you charles does anyone have an
interest to declare
in the items of business on the agenda
this morning
we move on to item three which is
minutes of previous meeting
to approve the minutes of the meeting of
the general purpose committee held on
the 30th of september 2020
copy of which is attached to the agenda
pack can i please have a proposal and
seconder
happy to propose chair david
stollenbergers
david saunders and the secondary
cancel a piper
does anyone have any objections to these
meeting minutes
i will take the silence as an approval
of the minutes
item 4 minutes of previous meeting to
approve the minutes of the meeting of
the general purpose committee held on
the 7th of april
2021 copy attached to the agenda pack
can i have a proposer and seconder
propose that councillor chesky
thank you
and a seconder
cancer auburn
does everyone agree with the minutes
nods of approval no objections okay
thank you they are approved thank you
charles
just to say chairman that counselor
rolfe has joined us
okay thank you
okay thank you canceroff so we are all
in attendance
item five exclusion of press and public
do members have any questions or any
ask any or any comments to make
i'm not sure have we got anybody charles
has anyone joined the meeting
i will read through the formalities
anyway so that then we can
make sure that it is all done correctly
so the recommendation is that the press
and public are excluded from the meeting
for addendum item
six as it contains exempt information as
defined in paragraphs one
two four and five and part one of
schedule 12a
of the local government act 1972 as
amended
please can i have a proposer and
seconder
council organ thank you seconded by
councillor bayford
thank you are there any objections to
that
okay that is approved
we will now have a minutes recess to
allow
charles to exclude the
press and public from the meeting so if
you could all just
mute your microphones and we will wait
for one minute
thank you